welcome to how to turn your dissertation
into a book an event brought to you by
the Graduate writing lab if you haven't
done so please sign in this one our
panel will be followed by individual
consultations which will be held in this
room so please don't go anywhere
if you signed up for an individual
consultation and if you got an email
from me
here your name should be listed also
near the sign-in sheet there is a
schedule for individual consultations so
please be sure to check your name and be
here to meet an editor afterwards all
right
well it's my pleasure to introduce our
four esteemed speakers Jennifer Bates is
executive editor the Yale University
Press Jennifer is particularly
interested in imaginative well-written
work that privileges subjects over
disciplines in such areas as world
religions biography biblical studies
Jewish Studies ethics moral psychology
the psychology of religion education and
children's literature she's also
interested in practical books on
research and writing Phillip Blumenthal
is the editor of literary studies film
studies in journalism at Columbia
University Press before that he worked
in the marketing department at the
Columbia University Press and at the
seminary co-op bookstore in Chicago
Priya Nelson is associate editor at the
University of Chicago Press where she
acquires new books and translations in
history anthropology and current events
themes of particular interest for her
scholarly list include the history of
ideas world history method religion
ethnographic writing economic
anthropology and social theory her
fields of acquisition reflect for
academic training at the University of
Chicago University of Texas in Austin
finally uh heather gold is assistant
editor here at the Yale University Press
where she oversees books and religion
and classics
she works in such fields as biblical
studies early Christianity Middle
Eastern Studies and Jewish Studies
heather is drawn to books that explore
religions through various lenses
including literature law art race and
culture so first Jennifer Philip and
Priya will offer
brief remarks and three issues that are
interest to most budding authors first
Jennifer will speak about how to prepare
a book manuscript Philip will discuss
how to think about picking a publisher
and Priya will offer advice as to how to
approach a publisher after their brief
remarks we'll begin the Q&A I'll start
with a few questions and then we'll open
it up to the questions from the audience
so Jennifer so this is a very hard
question for me to answer because you
know the longer I work in publishing the
more I realized there's no formulas and
that's part of what makes our job so
exciting but also very challenging and
it really is not a formula about
transforming a dissertation into a book
I'm gonna offer a couple of rough
guidelines but I'll confess that they
are somewhat exaggerated and that
dissertations take all kinds of forms
and you know a book can mean very
different things to very different
people
and I think you know depending on what
kind of audience you're trying to reach
with a book what that transformation
looks like is going to be very very
different
the two basic guidelines I'll offer and
again they're a little bit crude but the
first is that the you know dissertation
is really being written for a handful of
people the book conceivably is being
written for anyone who wants to pick it
up and I I think that there's a range
you know some some people have advisors
who really are encouraging them to write
this for a broader audit the
dissertation for the broader audience
and some people who are publishing their
first book are writing for a very narrow
sort of readership so the degree to the
degree of the transformation will be
determined by those two things where
you're starting we're trying to land but
I think it's one of the biggest
challenges people face when they're
trying to
make that transformation as to you know
going from writing for a group of people
that you've been in dialogue with you
know sort of what their expectations are
and what they're looking for to just
writing for this you know audience of
unidentified people so that's something
that has to be very carefully thought
through who are you writing for and why
and you know I think people who are on a
kind of faculty path are often writing
for professional reasons of their own I
think for publishers you know we're not
necessarily looking for someone who
wants to publish a book to get 10 year
we're looking for someone who is wants
to connect with some kind of readership
and has an idea that they want to
communicate with the world it's not that
we don't care about people's career
aspirations and concerns but I think we
have a slightly different set of
concerns the other kind of crude
guideline is you know that a
dissertation is is where you show your
mastery of a particular field or subject
and in a book that's not really needed
you know readers aren't coming looking
for your mastery of the subject they're
looking for an argument or a narrative
and you know you're using your doctor
documenting sources in whatever way is
you know sort of needed or demand my
material but you're not having to show
everything you've read whether that's in
the body of the text or even in the
notes so that's I think a big shift it's
very much related to the first thing I
brought up so those are two of the
guidelines but I will say that every
book that I've been through have gone
through with us it's been very different
and it typically does take years for
people to do this the books that I have
published that have been were originally
dissertations were several years in that
information from dissertation to book so
one thing I'll just leave you with
before I start talking is to kind of
think through carefully for yourself if
that is worth that investment of time
and one thing I'll I do see sometimes is
people who have a very narrow subject
who end up spending an inordinate amount
of time perfecting this and you know
they produce a very beautiful flawless
manuscript that is still going to have a
very limited readership and potential
you know in the market and their time
may have been better spent just you know
moderately revising this publishing it
may be some kind of existing
dissertation series and then working on
that next book to really make a kind of
dramatic jump between a dissertation
style writing and you know a book proper
so maybe that yeah so selecting a press
that you're interested in is is a little
bit more clear-cut each press you know
specializes in certain subject areas
that we don't publish in every different
area so for instance Columbia University
Press doesn't publish an art history and
then within each subject that we do
publish in there's there's often a kind
of subfield that we might work in I mean
I think a lot of publishers want works
this Jennifer was suggesting that sort
of speak to a lot of different audiences
but then you know presses will have for
instance a focus in let's say
Renaissance literature or modernist
literature so by investigating different
publishers websites and getting a sense
of what they do you know that should
help narrow down
where you should approach you should
also look for presses I think that
published in areas where your book has a
potential to crossover so for instance
if you're doing a book in Chinese film
does this press have a list in both film
studies and asian studies that gives the
press the opportunity to market and
promote your book to two different
audiences which is always both to the
presses advantage and to your advantage
as well as we start to narrow down your
thoughts about who you want to submit
your manuscript to I mean one very sort
of obvious thing is the books that
you've been using for your work and the
books that are on your bookshelf you
know what are the presses that are most
represented there and those are kinds of
the places that you want to approach
first I think you want to be part of a
kind of conversation I think when you
look at lists sometimes particularly
with with monographs you get a sense
like oh I understand why this is a YA
book or I understand why this is a
Chicago book there's a certain
commonality in either approach or
subject area and your editor will you
know therefore I think be in a good
position to get the right peer review
peer reviewers for your work who can be
very helpful in moving your manuscripts
along I would talk to you know your
mentors senior colleagues and get their
sense of their experience with different
presses was the response time good from
the editor was the copy editing and
production process did that go smoothly
and were those people in communication
with you did they feel that their book
was promoted adequately if it was a
scholarly book did it go to the right
conferences was it advertised in the
right scholarly journals and if it was a
trade book did they sort of understand
what that necessitated were they able to
kind of get that book out to a larger
audience were they advertising in places
like the New York Review of Books where
you can get a bigger tray audience on a
more practical level you know think
about the pricing of
I mean I think there's now more
commonality among the different presses
and how we're pricing it but some
presses price their books you know
closer to 100 or 110 dollars some
presses do in paperback right away more
often than others so if these things are
important to you that's another
consideration to take into account and
then you know finally how will the press
that you've selected affect you know
your 10 your possibilities I think some
tenure committees are much more
particular about publishing at certain
presses in order to get tenure and you
should sort of find out from your senior
colleagues you know are the presses that
are more preferable than others
and then finally another sort of area of
scholarly publishing to think about is
you know there's both the university
presses and then there's also the
commercial scholarly presses places like
Palgrave and Bloomsbury and rutledge
that aren't you know affiliated directly
with the university but do publish a lot
of I think particularly first books so
you know that's another option to think
about but again I would think about if
there are any sort n year implications
about that when you're approaching those
presses so I know that there's a lot of
confusion perhaps anxiety about how one
should talk to an editor about your work
and there are certain you know basic
things of good etiquette that one can
imagine pretty easily but I I maybe want
to talk this question in an unusual way
by talking about what makes a successful
communication whatever genre you're
using to communicate so whether it's
face to face email of a proposal and by
successful I don't mean that your work
is accepted every press that you
approach there are a lot of very very
smart people whose books are declined
for various reasons even you know Dean's
of the social sciences and
Provost get their books rejected
sometimes so it's a common fate and
you're in very good company the kind of
communication that is successful is one
that allows the editor to make an
informed decision about your project and
that's really crucial and that's
something that you can you can devote
your time to and hope to see some
returns on that investment so what does
an editor need to know first why must
the book be written in other words what
is the question and what is the answer
you'd be very very surprised by how many
people I talked to who give me the
impression that they know everything
about their subject except why it might
be interesting to somebody else and I
don't mean that in a disparaging way I
mean it with great sympathy and respect
because when you start to research a
dissertation or when you were searching
a book it's kind of like free diving
amid a sea of information and at a
certain point you get so deep into your
subject that that the density of facts
is so high and you just start to sink it
really takes some concerted effort and
presence of mind to kick back up to the
surface and see what what is interesting
here why did I get interested in this
subject in the first place what might be
exciting to other people so what is the
question what are you saying what do you
answer what's what's the answer to that
question you want to also convey that
you have the ability to say it well so
in written communication you want to pay
some attention to the quality of your
writing the the soundness of your
argument your ability to connect A to B
that's all very important and also
editors want to see a certain
distinctive voice and a certain kind of
originality we're not looking for
who is sort of robotic and their
execution of the methodology that
they've learned throughout their
graduate career we want something who is
well-trained yes has a certain rigor in
thought but then is adding something new
and exciting and this being a bit
creative we don't look for just one
brick that will fill a gap in a
literature that's not really what the
process that are represented here are
doing I mean we're trying to do
something that may reach it
interdisciplinary audience that provides
interesting answers to two interesting
questions so it's not merely a
performance as Jennifer was saying it's
not a performance of mastery at this
point and then showing a sense of you
know who the readership is that can also
be very very important in terms of
approaching an editor there's no sort of
generic advice and I also feel a bit
suspicious of you know telling you that
you must do such-and-such and in the
right order but I would say perhaps
there are a few things that you should
not do one of which is approaching
editor without knowing what they with
what those answers are so if you don't
know what you're what question you're
asking in your book if you don't know
what the answer is or what the thesis is
sort of been brought out line you don't
want to just start sending information
to an editor and saying here's the
chapter outline here's everything that
I've done in the past 10 years you
really want to have a sense of what that
book is about and why it's exciting so
don't don't try to soon give it some
time as Phillip said you you should know
a bit about the press that you're
approaching not all presses are the same
and you should have an idea of what they
do and who the editor might be there who
is working in your field I don't know we
can talk more about it if there are
specific questions that
there's some general thoughts can I just
add one thing one thing I forgot to
mention is you know when you're deciding
on a press you know how many different
presses you should approach and I think
it's you know good idea to to narrow it
down a little bit I mean try and find
the two or three presses that you really
are interested in and then it's okay to
send those presses you know proposal
about your work and in many cases if
they do decide to send it out they'll
ask for exclusivity so that they're the
only press that are sending out for
review but I think of that initial stage
it's good to sort of get a sense from
two or three different presses that's
you know I think every editor has a
different policy that that would be my
policy and you know if there's something
you know if there's a press that you
really want to work with and you haven't
heard from the editor but you've heard
from your second choice I would then you
know right back to that editor and say
you know I'm very interested in
publishing with your press I have this
other offer can you please let me know
what your timeline is for a decision
great thank you so much well I will ask
a few questions and then we'll open it
up to the audience so let me start with
a question that was posed by one of the
participants and I here's what the
person said how much in what way do I
need to revise my dissertation in order
to get it published how much of my
dissertation can I publish his articles
and feel free to answer one of you or do
you wanna answer it but everyone has to
say something say start on the circuit
so you know I do find it hard to answer
a question to answer like I
that most of the dissertations I've done
have been several years almost entirely
rewritten so you know they're taking the
research that they've done maybe the
basic thesis but almost entirely
rewriting the actual book that is not
necessarily what's needed for every
first book that's going to be published
so I don't necessarily recommend doing
that first you may want to have
conversations and get a sense of who
you're going to publish with and then
the second part of that question was
just about - how much of published I
think there might be different answers
to that here I don't really mind if
people are publishing articles partly
because I am assuming the book is going
to be rewritten you know we're not I'm
not usually publishing a book that has
you know four chapters that were
verbatim printed in different journals
they may have been published as
originally as articles but in order for
it to be part of a coherent book that
reads like a book and that probably is a
little bit different from a very
specialist readership that a particular
journal might have they're you know they
think they're they have to be edited
some people might say I don't know more
than half you know you don't want all of
the material out there I think this has
to do again with audience because if you
are publishing a general interest book
all the material maybe is available in
kind of more specialist you know
journals but you have recalled the
material it's being presented in a very
different way it might not be as much of
a concern versus if you are publishing
this book for a more specialist audience
and most of the materials already out
there then the you know the publisher
might start to feel like then why why
would we invest you know several years
in publishing this book if the material
is already there so I'd be curious what
both of you have to say I in my head I
kind of feel like
once there's more than you know 40% of
the book in articles I might start
getting a little bit nervous I think I
tend to be a little bit liberal here I
don't really mind I don't want to limit
someone's publishing you know journal
publishing track record early on yeah I
mean I feel similarly I mean I would
just want to to articles from from your
book and again with the assumption that
it's going to undergo change I mean a
standalone article is a very different
thing than a chapter in a book but but I
do like to see people have something
published before they publish their book
I mean I think particularly with first
book authors and particularly if it is
more of sort of a monograph we we want
the sense that this is an author who's
already part of a larger conversation
within their field and I think articles
are a really good way to do it it helps
kind of get your argument out there to a
broader audience even within the field
and then if you do - I you know you
might want to consider two different
types of journals so again using an
example of you know Chinese cinema you
might want to do something in a more in
a journal related to film studies and
then a journal related to Asian studies
to help you know reach those two
leadership's and the other thing that I
think at least at Columbia were looking
at more is has a softer published in
more general interest publications as
well and even if it is a scholarly kind
of book it's nice to see that on a CV
and they're places now like Los Angeles
- a few of books or public books mean in
the humanities that you know writing
about academic areas but for a kind of
broader audience and it's nice to see
when when writers have that kind of
reach as well on the question of how
much you should revise your dissertation
I think that is very difficult to answer
with with any kind of generic advice but
one thing that I would strongly
encourage everyone to do is go through
the exercise of writing a book propose
because it's this imaginative genre
where you you can sort of shape the book
in your mind in a way that will guide
you and in terms of your revisions if
you just start digging in going very
deep into details and revising chapter
by chapter you still might at the end of
the process not have the answers to the
questions that you set out asking so
putting your work in conversation with
other people figuring out what's really
exciting about your project all of this
can be done through writing a book
proposal and at that stage you have
something short to share with your
friends see what they think about it
tell you whether they think they think
you're on the right track gives you
something concrete to start circulating
among people who you trust and possibly
even editors so that I think is
something that will help you answer that
question in a way that is particular to
your project on the question of
publishing I agree I think it's good to
have one or two articles out there it
also helps you test the peer review
process so if you've never done that
before going through a peer review
process with one article can be an
immensely instructive not only because
you get to learn about the kind of
comments that people will make on your
dissertation project but just
familiarity with procedures and the way
that that timeline works in the way that
you think about revisions in light of
anonymous reports his point about
writing proposal I think that's really
helpful you might have a full manuscript
but you have to remember that editors
are looking at dozens and dozens of
manuscripts and proposals a week and so
we don't really have time if we get a
bunch of manuscripts on the mail to sit
down and read the whole thing so even if
you have the full manuscript it is
really important to write a proposal on
and that will answer all those questions
for us that you mentioned about who the
audience is
you know why this press why are you
submitting it to us and what are some
other books out there that you see your
book in dialogue with and then that will
help us assess whether we think this is
something we want to publish and then go
into reading the manuscript thank you
very much
my second question is and then we'll
open it up to the audience is someone
who just submitted one of these sort of
nerve-racking bits about the last part
of it was you know the ProQuest issue
and there is a lot of sort of
fear-mongering that you know we are
encouraged to put our dissertations on
ProQuest and you can delay by here or
two years but ultimately most people
don't really get their books out in two
years so the concern is that if your
book is widely if your dissertation is
available in ProQuest that some editors
might feel like a lot of your
information is already out there and
people can just access it for free why
should they pay for it what are you what
are your thoughts on this issue what
would you recommend graduates do is to
do or how to approach this issue think
about it I'm not really aware of all the
other instruments I'm really only aware
of the publishing concerns so I can only
speak to that so you know it might be a
very good idea to do that and in some
cases I think as a publisher we probably
encourage and just because it's so hard
for us to publish so many books that we
would want them to be available but for
us to invest you know all the resources
that go into publishing a book you know
me we can't do it for every every
dissertation proposal that we get on the
other hand you know if there's a book
that is of interest to us and we know
it's available for free already it'd be
some some hesitation there again it's a
question of how much
it's been changed if it's a dissertation
that went through all kinds of revisions
to into a book and the two really aren't
the same things at all then it wouldn't
be a big concern but if it's just you
know kind of editing a few things out
here and rewriting a couple sections
here I think there would be some concern
on the business part yeah I think I
agree with that I mean I used to tell
people that it's not a problem if you
got a dissertation will undergo
substantial revisions but you know again
this is something I would check with
your senior colleagues and see if it
affects you know tenure or anything like
that anyway I mean I know at Columbia at
least in the literature Department they
recommend embargoing it for a couple of
years
I mean apart I think it's to just to you
know your dissertation is you know again
it's written for you know three to five
people as many people on you know who
are on your dissertation committee and
do you really want to sort of have it
out in the public in that way before
you've really had a chance to start
thinking about how it's going to change
in the book form or before you have
other articles out for instance so you
know I think it's good to sort of have a
little time the dissertation is just
yours and not sort of out in the world
in that way this is a really interesting
question and I think there was a lot of
anxiety about it maybe a few years ago I
sense that had sort of dissipated a bit
because University process in particular
do spend a fair bit of time adding value
to whatever is there
and the books that we choose to publish
our months that we see a kernel of
promise and and we want to support that
project into book form but certainly if
you're looking at a press that's not
going to invest that kind of time where
you you are just hoping to get the book
out as quickly as possible that might be
a concern okay
I also don't know what the what the
downside of embargoing is just for a
couple of years if it's an option I know
the universities like to have a complete
record of everybody's dissertation but I
don't see any long-term negative side to
putting on an embargo if you have if
you're at the stage where you're still
finishing up the dissertation and you're
you're able to make this decision early
on in your in your postgraduate career
it's a good idea to save your great
title for the book don't use the same
title for for the dissertation in the
book make the table of contents more
exciting don't just retain the structure
and tweak a few things here and there so
think of the dissertation as the place
where you can really really geek out and
put all of the things that you wanted to
put in writing in the dissertation and
then you can call you know what's what's
the best material from each chapter and
make make the book a better product and
a leaner tighter argument more
interestingly written which has a better
table of contents and a much better
title so those are some small things
that you can do in order to distinguish
the projects and in order to make a
publisher more willing to take a look at
it
shouldn't ok so no one else has anything
to add we could open that up to Q&A
Pratt amah and Michelle both have
microphones and since we are recording
this session and the microphones are
vital to your voices being properly
recorded we ask you to speak into the
microphone and wait for one of them to
give the microphone to you you will not
hear yourself your voice will not be
amplified but don't worry you are it is
connected to the technology so basically
speaking to the microphone alright
anybody has any questions thank you all
so much that was super informative I
have a question about the wrote
mechanics or maybe better so the
etiquette of submitting to editors is it
customary to just dump a manuscript on
your desks and have it be responded to
or is there some more elaborate process
that has to be undertaken I was supposed
to address this question then I didn't
really adequately so I feel responsible
for and something it's a good idea to
find out who as the editor who's
attending your disciplinary conferences
so if you're in and apologists a find
out who's going to to play if you're a
historian find out who is going to be at
AJ there may be multiple editors a press
going to those meetings who are covering
different fields so for example Chicago
has a history auditor who does most the
American history I do global history and
and less that's based on us so find out
who the editors are send them an email
several weeks before a conference saying
this is the proposal I'd really love to
speak with you if you have time don't
wait until a week before the conference
because at that point everybody's
already booked up and sometimes for the
big disciplinary conferences like you
know anthropology is the biggest meeting
that I go to my schedule will be set a
month in advance because there are so
many people that need me to that I need
to see and certainly don't wait until
the conference is already in progress
this is such a curious thing that often
happens where I'll be checking my phone
when somebody says I'm here can I meet
you that's really too late and and one
one thing that you want to keep in mind
is that since most editors are fully
booked at those conferences it's not a
good idea to just show up and start
talking either because it's sort of a
stressful environment also you know you
don't want to make an uninformed
decision about a book so if you have
somebody who comes and tells you
something about the project you don't
really get a good sense of what it's
about you haven't written any read
anything that's been presented in a more
careful forum and so you don't want to
start an interaction like that it's best
if you can play on that at least a bit
and then as Philip was saying you know
it's it's a good idea just to get a
sense from a couple of different people
whether they're interested in the
project or not but if an editor I asked
cyou for exclusive consideration you
should grant that request especially if
they're gonna send the manuscript out
for review so a blind double submission
and you don't want to sort of behind one
editor's back submit and promise that
you're giving exclusive consideration to
both us
most of us understand all of the
pressures that there are early career
academics so if we're not able to
respond quickly enough and give you a
firm decision or a firm commitment it's
definitely okay to write and say I'm
facing a really strict timeline here I'm
on the job market do you have a sense of
whether this is a good fit or not that's
perfectly okay and I would I would just
say the more honest and open
communication the better yeah can I just
clarify something you said so then let's
say for someone who it's just starting
the process right they email you month
in advance you meet at the top police or
AAA and then should the person already
have a book proposal at that point so
what happens when you need at the truth
police is it like a 5-minute
conversation that the seasons gonna have
today or is it like a half an hour chunk
of time where you've already read some
of this stuff yeah it depends I mean
generally five minutes it's not really
enough to get a good sense of a project
so most editors that I know spend about
half an hour 35 minutes with each person
with their meeting and you may not you
may not get that many from every press
that cement to and that's okay
conversations can continue about you now
depending on how early on you are the
conversations can happen by email for
quite a long period of time well you can
call every editor on the phone so yeah
it's about half an hour 45 minutes
generally if you're at that stage where
you're having that kind of long
conversation you do have at least a
sense of what the project is about and
you hopefully may have already written
editors often will not want to take the
proposes just because you go home with
30 proposals in your stream air on the
flame think
what was I thinking you know I agree
with all of that I also have many
projects including first books that I've
signed up that I did not meet with
people at conferences they were just
emails that came in out of the blue and
you know I think each publisher has
submission guidelines on their websites
and you can basically follow those and
again there's not really a real formula
for how to do it I think just based you
know using a kind of basic guidelines of
etiquette and trying to imagine yourself
in someone else's shoes and being
overwhelmed with lots of things coming
in and you know the one thing I did want
to add is that many of the first books I
have signed up were recommended to me by
other people or they came in from that
author with a note saying you know Dale
Martin and though that shouldn't
department at Yale suggested I get in
touch with you and you know there are
days I'm getting 20 submissions a day
working in different areas and that's on
top of all the other work I'm doing so
it's very easy to to turn things down as
hard as it is emotionally we're doing it
all the time and it's most of the stuff
that comes in does not get even sent out
for review so anything that can
distinguish it and make the editor feel
like they are obligated to spend a
little time maybe it's that kind of
personal connection or if you've met
them somewhere
ending them that you've had this
conversation last year at a meeting or
you know at this panel at Yale or you
know you're their advisor suggested they
get in touch with you any of those kinds
of personal connections I find for me as
an editor make me sit up a little bit
and feel like I have to give a little
extra attention to this because there's
some sort of personal connection one
other thing I should say is that when
you do approach a press you generally
want to contact one editor first if that
other door is not the right person to
review the project she or he will
circulated among colleagues and so you
can feel assured that if you have
received a response from an editor that
that represents the decision of the
press so you don't have to send it to
multiple people you don't want to
receive a rejection from one on the door
and then send that to another usually
that has that communication has happened
and if you don't know who to contact at
a press
there's always an editorial director who
is their contact information is
generally listed on the website you can
just say I'm not sure who should be
reviewing this maybe you could point it
to the right person
thank you should we take another
question okay yes thank you all very
much I am I think I sort of have a
two-part question I was wondering you
talked about sort of the importance of
revising but I've also in conversation
with professors been warned against
holding on to the manuscript for too
long and sort of doing too many
revisions before it's gone out to
readers and so I was curious for your
thoughts on that and I guess more
generally if you could possibly walk us
through sort of what the stages are once
a manuscript has been sort of accepted
for first for readers I suppose and then
the revision process just to get a sense
of kind of what the range of time might
be for that and and I suppose what in
your minds determines if you read a
manuscript that you sort of think may
need work but has promised kind of what
that what that looks like I suppose
since I've sort of gotten the impression
that books do come in
um you know not absolutely finished but
somehow seem promising yeah I mean I you
know the review the the review process a
peer review process is very sort of
helpful and integral for that reason and
yeah we don't really necessarily expect
that a work will be perfect and we are
trying to find you know something that
has a lot of great promise even if it's
not quite there yet but we do want to
make sure at least for myself you know
that it is far enough along that it
won't start getting bogged down too much
in the peer review process you don't
want to have this sort of endless
back-and-forth between the author and
you know the readers and then the
faculty board at the press so I mean
again I think it's a hard thing sort of
quantifying any certain way but but you
know I want sort of a fairly polished
manuscript but you're right I mean you
don't want to sort of there are people
who just get to sort of obsessed with
their dissertations are boundlessly
revising and you know there is a point
where you sort of have to let that go in
terms of how the process goes at least
at Columbia
I would say generally I mean once we
decide to send something out for a
review that process generally takes
about you know anywhere from about three
to four months or maybe two to four
months depending and so what will happen
is first it will be you know sent to the
peer reviewers we tell them give them
about four to six weeks to give back the
report sometimes they might miss that
mark and then after that the author will
have the opportunity to respond to the
suggestions made by the peer reviewer
and that's a really important part I
think of the process and an editor will
work with you on that you know we really
want a sense that this authors taken
seriously the comments that have been
made by the readers and Cerf has a
strategy now for how they're going to
revise when it can be a difficult
process that thing for authors and you
know I often encourage them to take a
day or two to sort of soak it all in and
then after that we have an internal
meeting and essentially the purpose of
that meeting is to decide is this ready
to go to our
looking bored are the reports strong
enough have they
you know recommended offering a contract
and has the author responded well and
then and then it goes to our faculty
board and they are sort of the final
arbiters to decide whether or not we
should offer a contract for the project
so our process is very similar to that
with a couple differences mainly our
faculty board meeting happens a little
bit later so we will have our internal
meeting after a project is reviewed and
the author's responded and at that point
we'll decide with all of our editors and
all the different department heads at
the press whether we think the book is
right for us and whether we feel that we
can offer offer a contract and if so we
would make sure that the reports are
positive and that or if there are some
negative comments that the author has
responded I would lead to them and once
book is under contract and we feel that
the manuscript is in good shape and the
author has a good plan for revisions
then you bring it to our faculty board
and that's kind of the last hurdle
before we get the final manuscript that
we look at and that goes into copy
editing and production I think generally
I would want an author to take things as
far as they possibly could and have it
in the best possible shape you don't
want someone sending you something
I have to do this and that and I'm gonna
do more work later because you know you
sort of have one shot with the house and
with an editor and you want to be able
to make the best possible impression
likely there will be further rounds of
revision that you will go through after
that point but I would really try to get
it you know if you if you want to
publish with a lot of the bigger
University presses and the more
distinguished press if you're just
trying to kind of move on you know move
on to the next thing get the book
published as quickly as possible that
would be a different model Thank You
Jennifer
next question Eleanor
so thank you so much for this
opportunity so that's also kind of
two-part question and the first part is
a lot of the things that you said about
how to give a book proposal are really
surprisingly similar seem to me to the
process of doing a post doctoral fellows
oh like you know you need to have the
why was important who's your audience
and how you intend to revise your
dissertation into the book and so I
wondered if you could say you prefer
people who have actually gone through
something like that I post are in a
sense and so therefore the timeframe
would be like one or two years at least
or pork in this rotation to go from that
to the book and the other part is you
recommend that people talk before to
summer people in your faculty board so
like I happen to know a little bit of
the rest I'd be interested in some
people you know some professors that are
in similar things is it back mandible
that to approach them first just to get
a mind yeah or not I know it's just very
nerve-wracking boxes it is a very
nerve-racking process and I just want to
offer perhaps one note of encouragement
which is there are so much conflicting
information about publishing out there
and you may hear different things from
different people you make your different
things from one advisor rather than
another that's okay and part that
reflects the sort of diverse environment
in which we find ourselves where there
are many different kinds of publishers
every editor were sort of differently so
it's definitely an anxiety producing
situation for
good reasons as one of our panelists
mentioned before we don't have a real
stake in the career trajectory itself
you know we want our offers to be
prominent in their field and we want
them to do well but what we're really
judging is the as the book itself and a
lot of us work with known academics too
so the question of whether we prefer to
receive something at a certain stage
from a postdoc or a system professor
that doesn't matter really very much at
all and if you're using that time
productively I mean this goes back to
the question of how much one should be
revising it's a question of the quality
of the revision not the quantity
so there is a danger of getting stuck in
sort of an endless fine grained revision
that happens over a number of years and
then at the end of the process you might
not even have a publishable book so you
know spending a couple of months pausing
thinking about what's exciting talking
to your spouse talking to your nephew of
talking to your friend whoever to find
out how you can communicate something
that you've spent so many years of your
life devoted to in a way that is
understandable to somebody who's a non
specialist can be crucial even if you're
writing a specialist book so take a
couple of months pause think about it
have a plan for quality revisions and
then do it and get it done so whatever
that process is whatever works for you
is is the right one I think too
sometimes reading the books that are
just in your field can be a little
misleading particularly if they were
published even even you know fourteen
years ago the field has changed a lot so
sometimes I think it's you know if
you're if you're just writing a
scholarly book you're not trying to
reach beyond a scholarly audience even
thinking of the feet the books in fields
that are different than yours in reading
them and see
you know what you can tolerate as a
reader and what you can follow and you
know what would interest you in you know
if you're an anthropologist what would
interest you in literary studies so that
that can be a useful exercise and I
think is another note of encouragement
for me it doesn't really matter if
someone just finished their PhD or if
they are an incredibly distinguished
professor so at Harvard you know I'm
concerned with the book and what I think
we're gonna be able to do with the book
so in a way publishing is more
democratic I think then academia itself
you know in its we do like to see that
they're her you know you've gotten some
awards or but it's a little bit
different I think it's much more focused
on the actual product and you know to
some degree personality what someone can
bring to it what how they're going to
breathe life into the project how
they're going to help us publish it how
they're going to help us promote it so I
think postdocs are great but it's mainly
because it gives the author time it's
not really about you know what that
signals to me necessarily I think she'll
side questioning about faculty boards
yeah it can be helpful I've had prot you
know I have a project that's gonna be
coming in to me soon that was a
dissertation here at Yale that was
recommended to me by someone on our
faculty board it's the same as any kind
of connection you know they don't
determine what we publish but it could
help yeah I mean I think to think of
them more as scholars in the field
rather than necessarily members
community and if you already have a
relationship with them that makes sense
but if you're just reaching out to them
out of the blue that might not make
sense so I think if there's already a
connection or a reason outside it's just
wanting the book published with the
press they're affiliated with that
you're reaching out to them then I think
it makes sense
I think the point about weeding is such
a crucial one and reading across
disciplines is great also try reading
popular books so if you're a historian
read some trade history and get a sense
for how it's written the way that a
table of contents is organized or a
thesis unfolds the way that for example
a journalist might discuss a
conversation that she had is similar to
the way an anthropologist might record a
conversation that was had in the field
so getting this kind of sense of what
people are reading and popular history
or current events books might help you
if you're Jason feels like reading a
book reviews to seeing what the new New
Republic is reviewing and what the New
York Times Book Review you might not be
striving for that but just to have some
kind of awareness of what the
environment is I think it's really
valuable so we have time for just one
more question
it's window
so much for this incredibly constructive
and I'll just wanting your feet perhaps
you could speak to the reasons why
prospective author might pursue a
contract with like some of the more
prominent publishers in this country
versus like Oxbridge publishers thank
you I tend to think of Oxford and
Cambridge as you know in many ways very
comparable to a lot of what we do I mean
there's certainly bigger and they have
other things that we don't do but you
know they both have editorial offices
here in the United States and their
processes are fairly similar to what we
do I mean I think perhaps you know one
thing to think about is these are very
large organizations and sometimes you
know you might not get the same kind of
attention that you would at a smaller
press where you know they're not the
only so many different projects so that
kind of relationship might be a little
bit different
I think another helpful way of figuring
that out is if you are going to a
conference walk into the book exhibit
and look at the publishers boots and see
what's at the Oxford booth you know how
did they publish their books versus
Chicago or Columbia or Yale that'll give
you a sense of that and then I think
also as Philip said earlier figuring out
what's important to use so whether price
point is important that's something
that's important to authors and changes
very very rapidly over the years and you
know whether having your book available
as an open access ebook or in paperback
first you know figuring out what's
important to you and then looking at
what different publishers do because it
is going to be different for
every author in every book thank you
very much so let me just ask one more
question and then we'll move on to
individual consultations so my final
question for all panelists is if you
could only give a single piece of advice
to a graduate student or a postdoctoral
fellow hoping to publish his or her work
what would it be I you know I always
think the most important thing is just
write the book that you are most
passionate about and let the chips fall
Beibei because you know they're it's a
very unpredictable process you could
write the most brilliant proposal that's
very publishable but you there just
isn't quite the right publisher or
editor out there and it seems to fall
between cracks books come out and don't
get the attention that people hope for
and you've invested years you know I
think to just do the work that you feel
most deeply inspired to do and usually
that translates into some sort of
success but you can't count on that
success so for you know to feel like
that time and energy that you've put
into the project was was something that
you needed to do for yourself yeah I
agree with that I think but I would say
something I think that Priya was
suggesting as well and have a clear
sentence more practical I mean have a
clearer sense of what's at stake in your
project what you want to say and to whom
you want it to be said and you know in
terms of audience me there's no sort of
right or wrong audience I mean they're
great books that we published that will
reach 500 meters and they're great books
that we publish that will reach 5000 and
they both have a kind of value for the
kind of publish
we do yeah I think what I'm gonna say is
gonna echo both of those comments uh one
of the really difficult things about
being in a situation doesn't early
scholar and trying to revise a book is
that you know there is an obvious answer
to why must my book be written it's
because there are job market concerns
and there's tender issues so you have to
bracket that in your mind and hold it
there you know somewhere and in a
confined space that doesn't overpower
you and and some kind of anxious and
nervous state and try to reconnect with
what why must the book be written from
an intellectual standpoint what is the
really crucial thing that's driving this
process I think everybody gets into
academia because they're excited about
ideas there's a tremendous amount of
pressure that dulls that excitement a
bit so recapturing a sense of wonder and
your project curiosity finding what is
still there and frankly if it's not
still there maybe you could get your
dissertation on quickly and find
something else or cannibalize their
dissertation and write articles for some
places where you're going to be teaching
that's also an acceptable way of finding
a long-term position so take a moment
think about how you want to spend the
next few years of your life and try to
recapture a sense of excitement about it
yeah I say all of those things
but also I think it's really important
to let your personality shine through
and show your passion and why you're
writing this book and why you're
devoting your career to this because at
the end of the day I think publishing is
all about relationships
your relationship with your editor your
relationship with your reader and I
don't want just to read I think someone
use the word robotic a robotic proposal
or manuscript I want to see who you are
and from the very first letter you write
to me when you submit your proposal to
once you
have a finished book I think I want to
see who the author is and you know feel
your presence when I'm reading your book
thank you all
this is amazing advice and thank you for
all the other really useful nuggets of
advice we would like to thank you all
for participating